Is the Democrats' taboo on calling out Israel finally breaking?
For decades, Democratic Party leaders have embraced Israel as an ally that could do no wrong,
and have marched in lockstep with Washington DC 's Israel lobby, AIPAC.
But
is the Democrats' love affair with Israel coming to an end?
For many years,
even Democrats who were privately critical of Israeli policies
deemed it too politically risky to make those views public.
But then,
in 2016,
this happened:
If we are ever going to bring peace...
we are gonna have to treat the Palestinian people
with respect and dignity.
The fact that an American presidential candidate
— who also happened to be Jewish —
demanded on national TV that Palestinians be treated with respect and dignity,
and then received an applause was extraordinary to witness.
It meant a lot, for a lot of reasons, actually.
Bernie Sanders was interesting not only because
he was one of the few
major Democratic candidates for president who was critical of Israeli policy,
but the interesting thing is that he actually found that
people liked what he said.
Bernie's statement about Palestinian rights broke the U.S. political convention
of discussing Palestinians only through the lens of Israel and Israeli security.
It's true that most Americans do care about Israel's security.
I think they don't buy the argument that this is what's going on here.
Because they see the occupation that's been there
since 1967 unending.
They know a lot of the humiliation that takes place
is totally unrelated to security.
So I think in the end,
people see this not so much as an anti-Israel stand,
they see it as a global human rights, international law
democracy stand.
But Bernie's statement didn't come out of nowhere.
Believe it or not
Barack Obama gets some credit for acknowledging the Palestinian struggle.
In 2009,
he spoke about the hardships that Palestinians face:
the displacement,
the oppression,
the pain
and the humiliation.
Many wait in refugee camps in the West Bank,
Gaza
in neighboring lands for a life of peace and security
that they have never been able to lead.
They endure the daily humiliations
large and small,
that come with occupation.
He also directly linked the Palestinian plight with Israel's creation.
It is also undeniable that the Palestinian people have suffered
in pursuit of a homeland.
For more than 60 years,
they've endured the pain of dislocation.
Obama's speech was seen as sympathetic to Palestinians.
And according to the New York Times,
it upset some Israelis
and American supporters of Israel because
"they saw the speech as elevating the Palestinians to equal status."
But it's years of advocacy work by progressive groups have helped push
the narrative of Palestinian rights to be included in the Israel-Palestine debate.
And intersectionality has played a vital role in this.
Black activists,
media personalities
and members of the Black Lives Matter movement
have shown up for the Palestinians, calling for an end to the Israeli occupation.
I think there's been a huge increase in actually just seeing the connections between
struggle between people of color in the U.S.
and poor people, and people of color all around the world.
We came here to Palestine to stand in love and revolutionary struggle
with our brothers and sisters.
When I went to Palestine, obviously I saw many, many connections
between what was happening to Palestinian people
and what's happening to Black people in the U.S.
Looking at a place like Gaza in particular,
like many of the horribly oppressive practices
are then shipped and used.
Police departments in the U.S. and here in Florida,
and the Miami police department
have gone to get trained by the IDF
several times.
And so we're seeing an evolution of our policing system
that actually really mirrors what has happened in Palestine.
And Palestinians,
both in the occupied territories and abroad,
have in return vocalized support for Black civil rights.
You know, Ferguson protesters who were protesting the murder of
Michael Brown,
when they were met with this huge attack from the
Ferguson Police Department and the spraying of tear gas...
I think it was like Palestinian activist Mariam Barghouti
who was actually like, here's how you protect yourself from the tear gas.
In 2015,
the Black-Palestinian Solidarity campaign released a video
that showed the similar challenges facing both communities.
Capitalism,
white supremacy,
Zionism,
imperialism -
all of these systems actually thrive when we're isolated from one another.
So,
when I don't see my struggle as connected to other people,
I internalize those systems and think, oh my problems are my problems
my community's problems are my community's problems.
But when we're actually able to draw connections,
it really reveals that no,
there are larger systems.
These are not my problems,
these are not my community's problems.
This is actually oppression.
I think solidarity on a fundamental level actually allows us to see the broader system
that we're fighting against.
We might not be experiencing the exact same struggles,
but we're definitely up against the same oppressor.
And there's also been more American progressive Jews
who see Israel's oppression of Palestinians
as contradictory to Jewish values.
It's no longer the case that
Jewish communities can expect
young Jews and a future generation [of Jews] to be in lockstep
and refuse to critique Israeli policy
and refuse to stand for Palestinian freedom.
In fact,
a report by the Anti-Defamation League
and an Israeli think tank
identified intersectionality
as "an emerging challenge"
to the "pro-Israel network."
After I went to Palestine and we came back, we were working on
a policy platform for the movement for Black Lives
and it was like,
how can we not include the struggles of
what's happening to Palestinian people?
We got a lot of backlash for that choice,
which I think is again,
a sign of how scared they are of the potential of solidarity,
how scared they are to lose bases of support in the U.S.
Viewing the issue as a matter of equality and human rights for Palestinians
is increasingly popular among the new wave of
Democrats that have entered Congress.
We have now,
for the first time, these elected officials in DC who are willing
to say the hard truth even though it comes at a great risk to them.
One of the most important ways that these new elected officials are challenging
the Democratic establishment's traditional stance with Israel is that
they're refusing to play by their rules,
right?
They're supporting BDS,
the Boycott, Divestment and Sanctions movement.
They're supporting Palestinian human rights.
and they're calling out groups like AIPAC.
That also reflects the trend among Democratic Party voters.
A 2018 study showed that self-identified liberal Democrats
are more likely to side with Palestinians than Israelis,
compared to moderate and conservative Democrats,
who generally still side with Israel.
You know, I think for far too long
Palestinians have really been dehumanized
in the American discourse.
And in the past number of years,
the realities and the root causes
of Palestinian dispossession are coming to light.
And this shift away from unwavering support of Israel
might be worrying establishment Democrats.
If the Democratic establishment is not worried,
they should be.
Because the polls show the rapid increase of young Americans
critical of Israel and in support of Palestinian human rights -
both Jewish and not Jewish.
A few prominent and veteran Democrats
have actually started a new group with the aim of supporting candidates in 2020
who are vocally pro-Israel.
In fact, the group's president told the New York Times that
"There are a few discordant voices, but we want to make sure
that what's a very small problem doesn't metastasize into a bigger problem."
Polls show a long-term trend that counts against the establishment:
Support and sympathy for Israel is declining among younger voters and people of color.
One survey showed that younger Americans were less likely
to see Israel as an "ally,"
and the same goes for women
and Black
and Hispanic Americans.
And yes,
the divide between Democrats and Republicans on Israel
is also widening.
In fact,
the partisan divide on that issue
is now wider than at any point since 1978.
Republican support for Israel is also fueled by
the Christian right.
According to a Pew Research survey,
self-identified Republicans sympathizing more with Israel than Palestinians
has incresed from 50%
to 79% since 2001.
Over the same period,
Democrats sympathizing for Israel
declined from 38% to 27%.
The Democratic base is demanding that kind of integrity from their politicians
and they know that there's no way to talk about human rights,
or
talk about racial justice,
if you are silent about the issue of justice for Palestinians.
And so, the Democratic base is changing
and are electing people and demanding that their elected officials
reflect their values.
The shifting gratitudes in the Democratic Party towards Israel
means that there's someone else that's probably getting a bit uneasy.
AIPAC.
According to Center for Responsive Politics,
AIPAC spent $3.5 million in 2018 on lobbying,
essentially helping maintain a pro-Israel Congress.
Clearly they are influential.
Now, has this disruptive change that has taken place
in the rules of the game affect them?
Of course it has.
Some Democrats remain very much in Israel's corner.
They speak in support of Israel and attend AIPAC conferences.
Oh,
and occasionally say things like this:
The view of Palestinians
is simple.
"Well,
the Europeans treated the Jews badly,
culminating in the Holocaust,
and they gave them our land as compensation."
Of course we say it's our land
the Torah says it.
But they don't believe in the Torah.
So,
that's the reason there is not peace.
But as the Democratic Party attempts to put on a united front
when it comes to the subject of Israel,
it wouldn't be wrong to say that even within the establishment,
there are undercurrents of discontentment with Israel.
And Netanyahu plays a big role in that.
A lot of Democrats have also witnessed that this Israeli government,
the current Israeli government, has been led
by Prime Minister Netanyahu who most Democrats
don't like,
not only because they don't like the values that he projects
and the policies that he undertakes on Israel-Palestine,
but also because they see him as taking a position in American politics
much more sympathetic to the Republican Party.
Back in 2015,
he annoyed Democrats by going over the administration's head
to appeal directly to Congress
to oppose President Obama over the Iran nuclear deal.
And Israel's killing of Palestinian protesters along the fence in Gaza
also attracted criticism.
With the party's progressive wing demanding that the Democrats
end their silence on Palestinian human rights
but the establishment dragging its heels...
what does that mean for the Democratic Party?
For whatever reason,
a lot of young Democrats have latched
onto this issue as kind of a litmus test for whether or not a Democratic candidate
is genuinely in harmony with the on their values, and it's likely
to put a lot of pressure on political candidates as we move forward.